el grupo del señor henry tiene 64
crayones pero al final del año solo
quedan 31 cajones cuántos crayones se
han usado y nos ponen un dibujo por aquí
nunca y el inicio del año había 64
crayones aunque ya que tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
6 paquetes de 10 crayones o sea 6
decenas de crayones y 4 unidades o sea
64 crayones pero luego al final del año
sólo nos quedan 31 crayones aunque ya
los tenemos por aquí 31 son 3 decenas y
una unidad y por aquí los tenemos 3
decenas de crayones una decena dos
decenas tres decenas y una unidad
entonces cuántos crayones se han usado
y ponle pausa al vídeo e inténtalo por
tu cuenta muy bien estoy suponiendo que
ya lo intentaste y vamos a resolverlo
juntos y bueno hay varias formas de
resolver este problema pero por ejemplo
si no tuviéramos este dibujo por aquí
podemos decir hay 64 crayones ponemos
por aquí 64 y luego pues el grupo del
señor henry ha usado algunos de esos 64
crayones entonces pues si se han usado
esos crayones tenemos que restar los
entonces vamos a restar pero pues
todavía no sabemos cuántos crayones son
los que se han usado entonces vamos a
dejar un espacio por aquí ok pero a los
64 crayones que teníamos al inicio del
año le restamos los crayones usados y
eso nos tiene que dar igual al número de
crayones que tenemos ahorita y nos lo
dicen por aquí al final del año sólo
quedan 30
crayones entonces quedan 31 crayones
entonces tenemos la cantidad de crayones
con los que empezamos y luego le
restamos la cantidad de crayones que
usamos y nos tiene que quedar igual a la
cantidad de crayones que tenemos ahorita
ahora lo que nosotros queremos saber es
esta cantidad de aquí la cantidad de
crayones que se han usado aunque hay 64
- esta cantidad es igual a 31 y queremos
averiguar cuál es esta cantidad entonces
pues podemos intercambiar el 31 con esta
cantidad misteriosa y entonces obtenemos
que 64 menos 31 es igual a la cantidad
que queremos encontrar y como hice esto
como le hice para intercambiar el 31 con
este espacio pues lo que hice fue
imaginarme 64 cosas
ok digamos que por aquí tenemos
un bloque que representa 64 cosas
si tenemos por aquí 31 cosas y luego
este de aquí es nuestro espacio vacío la
cantidad que queremos encontrar que de
hecho hasta le puedo poner un signo de
interrogación porque no sabemos cuánto
vale y entonces este bloque de aquí
representa la cantidad que queremos
encontrar entonces aquí podemos ver que
31 más nuestro espacio vacío es igual a
64 y también que si tenemos 64 y le
restamos el espacio vacío nos quedan 31
y bueno pues también si tenemos 64 y le
restamos 31 lo que nos queda es este
espacio vacío
entonces nada más tenemos que averiguar
cuánto es 64 menos 31 y 64
31 y lo vamos a hacer por aquí aunque
ahí tenemos 64 menos 31 aunque ahí
empezamos por las unidades
tenemos cuatro menos uno y eso son tres
y luego pasamos a las decenas tenemos
seis decenas menos tres decenas y esas
son tres decenas así es que esta
cantidad el espacio vacío
esta cantidad de aquí también es 33 y lo
podemos checar aquí aunque hay 64 menos
33 es 31 y 64 menos 31 es 33
entonces se han usado 33 crayones
ahora ya que tenemos este dibujo por
aquí pues vamos a utilizarlo para
encontrar esta respuesta de otra forma
ya sabemos que se han usado 33 crayones
pero ahora vamos a encontrar la
respuesta tomando otro camino que
tenemos aquí dibujado que al inicio del
año tenían 64 crayones ok tienen
dibujados aquí los 64 crayones tienen 6
decenas y 4 unidades aunque tienen una
decena 2 3 4 5 6 decenas y 4 unidades 1
2 3 4 y al final del año terminan con 31
crayones hay tres decenas uno dos tres y
una unidad 31 así es que cuantos
crayones usamos para ir de 64 crayones a
31 crayones
saber veamos aquí nada más tenemos tres
decenas y empezamos con seis decenas así
es que usamos una dos tres decenas
estas tres escenas las usamos tres de
escenas
y ahora veamos cuántas unidades usamos
aunque empezamos con 4 unidades y ahora
solo tenemos una unidad entonces tenemos
que haber usado 3 unidades
una vez
entonces si tenemos 64 crayones al
inicio del año
y quitamos tres decenas de crayones y
tres unidades
nos quedan exactamente la misma cantidad
de crayones que teníamos al final del
año entonces podemos ver que usamos tres
paquetes de 10 crayones y otros 3
crayones entonces cuántos crayones
usamos pues usamos 3 paquetes de 10 o
sea 3 decenas y luego otros 3 crayones
jose a